votre vidéo vous est présenté par
victoria tirer talents.com vous avez
plus de 5000 follower sur vos réseaux
sociaux
venez nous rejoindre et devenez
influenceurs grâce à victoria tirer
talents.com
il a donné un cours de français
l'animateur belles séquences et c'est
pas évident de se retrouver dans un
axiome enfin bon gad elmaleh les plus
grands d europe en amérique un bon jour
mais qui faisait rire le public et le
présentateur jean c'est si on avait une
proposition de faire touche pas à mon
poste en américains et on va sur un tour
de table américain qu'avez-vous
producing bande
l'avantagé que le jean michel maire est
universel tu vois on le mettra en italie
et ça serait passé au goulot engagé
aucune un mot il le connaît dans toutes
les langues
merci à sa malin je ne sais pas mignon
petit événement ce soir car pour la
première fois vous allez retrouver les
deux pascal de la télévision vous savez
qu'ils viennent en aide aux ados
récalcitrants qui cassent des portes qui
tape sur les parents il y aura le grand
phare sa première participation je crois
dans touche pas à mon poste
le grand frère nt1 sera là il sera face
à pascal soin tests
vous et vous avez vu tout un show ça n'a
rien
et bien c'est pas grave vous avez pascal
le grand frère voilà ce fait la photo et
vous aurez le contraire qui se passe
il y aura deux grands frères à paris qui
pourra faire plein de choses vous allez
voir je voulais faire absolument un
petit coucou jeu hier j'étais en
belgique à vous vous en moquez mais je
vous le dis quand même
et jamais mais je vous assure dans les
rues je ne pensais pas qu'on regarde et
touche pas à mon poste que les amateurs
incroyable alors surtout les belges que
j'ai adoré ces qui dit appelle pas par
ton nom il t'appelle par le nom de ton
émission c'est à dire que à chaque fois
sur trottoir d'en face
touche pas à mon poste certains maillons
faibles et celle d'occuper les aux
nouvelles
pascal on ne nous qui est plus à dos
mais qui ne fait pas qu'ils arrêtent pas
de gueuler cgil je les lui demande et
donc il va venir contre vous allez vous
installer devant gilles vincent pascal
impressionne on est bien d'accord
le principe est simple j il ya peut-être
quelqu'un qui vous posent problème
souvent c'est la merde c'est le père un
collègue un patron peu importe vous
tapez et vous lâchez tout essayé à mieux
après en télé live piqué lequel et vous
parlez on va parler de cyril au jeu
posner négoce et cyril ouais donc que
pensez vous de lui j'avais un compliment
jamais à l'appel de pékin mathieu ce
couple j'ai pas le droit de crier des
jaloux oui on dit de lui je suis jamais
[ __ ] thuy
lou buscaillou match pour lui
ah les nouvelles questions quels sont
les accessoires coquins que l'on peut
utiliser pas dans la boîte
eric arbitres menottes fouet cravachait
bandido
[Applaudissements]
je sais pas d'où ça sort et où ça va
aller mais en tout cas bravo parce qu'il
n'ya pas eu une once d'hésitation
maintenant tu fous et cravache est ce
que je note que c'est françois roux bien
en soit si venez françois ont fait du
télévie de btp qui reçoit c'est les
couleurs et françois bien rentrer plus
que la france a pour tous les goûts et
les âges il côtoie qui a peu bougé au
côté massive asie de news est vraiment
parce que la forme c'est vrai je
voudrais juste dire ils sont assis à
côté c'est pas facilement 100 cas
certaine tension alors on parle de
gilles verdez les ouragans sont pas si
ça va j'essaie bois et ben tu vas voir
le profil
vous vouliez vous avez déjà fait un truc
pour décrocher un poste deux mots prends
moi oui c'était un homme ou une femme
que vous tapez un nom
et alors il vous avez pris à huy
trichet a dit
fallait pas mettre de photos on avait
dit pas de blog sur le physique ça c'est
nul en foutez pas près de me demander si
j'avais fait quelque chose de spécial
n'en avoir fait quelque chose spéciale
quand je les voulais être embauchés en
doute va on s'en doute car françois
comme journaliste comme je connaissais
pas du tout personne je n'ai aucun
piston et rien parce que je venais de
provins jeunes et de l'est je me suivant
boucher en fête du cheval comme coursier
sans dire que j'ai des joies et si
j'étais concours c'est ce qui m'a permis
de découvrir paris en même temps et on a
force d le court c'est ben j'ai connu
tout le monde dans le journal évidemment
on lui dit qu'est ce t'as fait comme
étudie les belges que l'étude de
journalisme ni bègue tu fous sur un
scotch dibaba ce que j'ai pas de travail
madiba pose ton scoot et bien prend le
boulot de journaliste d'âge et embaucher
même vieux aussi un peu le vendredi on
fait avec ce qu'on a mais c'est ce que
c'est intéressant c'est qu'on découvre
d'autres personnalités vous auriez cru
aux mecs prends moi sinon j'arrête de
coucher avec ta femme tout comme ça mais
pas de la presse